Hey guys, it's Jan here.
As always, Game Of Thrones kept up its insane
kill rate in Season 5.
Well, you know "All men must die."
Ok, maybe not all men, but a hell of a lot
of them, and a good deal of women too!
So, in this video I'm going to run through
my five most memorable deaths from this season.
But just before I get started, I've got a
great giveaway to celebrate the 10th anniversary
of our friends at Genki Gear.
To mark the occasion, they've designed 10
cool new T-shirts, including the one I'm wearing,
and you can win one of them!
All you need to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video!
Ok, let's countdown the top five deaths in
Season 5!
The fact he's still alive in the books and
even has a point of view chapter in Winds
of Winter didn't save Ser Barristan Selmy
from getting the chop this season.
Then again showrunners Benioff and Weiss did
send a pretty clear message to A Song Of Ice
And Fire readers in Season 5 when Selyse told
Shireen, 'You have no idea what people will
do; all your books and you still don't know'.
Still, we should have known Ser Barristan
was as good as gone when he started reminiscing
about the good old days, waxing lyrical about
the musical exploits of Dany's brother, Rhaegar
Targaryen, and then Dany told him to 'go,
sing a song for me.'
After which the show cut to Hizdahr zo Loraq
saying, 'all men must die, but not all can
die in glory.'
At least Ian McElhinney, who plays Ser Barristan,
got his wish for Selmy to go out fighting,
taking out a slew of Sons of the Harpy before
being fatally wounded.
Hardhome introduced us to a cool new character,
in the form of female wildling Karsi, before
rudely ripping her away, in typical Game Of
Thrones style!
Yes, after some cracking lines and some kick-ass
action, it was time for Karsi to join the
great ice army.
Earlier we'd seen her send off her young daughters
on a Night's Watch boat, with the words 'I'm
right behind you, I promise!'.
So, it was all too horrifyingly fitting that
after she fought off so many eerie attackers,
she was felled by six child wights.
Even though they were basically undead killing
machines, Karsi could NOT bring herself to
use her weapons against those mini-wights.
But not to worry, thanks to the Night's King,
wildling Karsi's now wight Karsi…
hmmm, why do I get the feeling that this is
all going to end horribly?!
Arya was finally able to cross Kingsguard
Meryn Trant off her hit-list this season,
in a scene that felt like it was straight
out of a horror movie!
Obviously, that's not what Cersei intended
when she sent him off to Braavos with Mace
Tyrell.
But not only did Trant kill our favourite
sword-master Syrio Forel, he also turned out
to be a child beater and paedophile!
I suppose we could have guessed as he certainly
didn't have any qualms about assaulting Sansa
when Joffrey told him to.
Still, that was one hell of a brutal kill
by Arya, stabbing him in the eyes and then
repeatedly in the chest, stomach, and back,
and then finishing him off with a slit to
the throat, which made me think of how her
mother Catelyn killed Walder Frey's wife and
was then killed herself at the Red Wedding.
And I don't think it's any coincidence that
that Season 3 episode and the Season 5 finale
were both directed by David Nutter.
Oh, no, Jon Snow, maybe Ygritte was right
when she said you know nothing!
And obviously he wasn't much of a public speaker
either, otherwise he'd have been able to communicate
just how freakin crucial it was to get the
Wildlings on side in the fight against the
White Walkers!
Actually come to think of it, it's a shame
Jon didn't have a mobile phone and a selfie
stick during Hardhome.
Then he could have snapped a pic or taken
a Vine of himself making a big frowny face
and two thumbs-down, with the Night's King
and the marauding wights in the background.
Maybe that would have convinced the Night's
Watch that Jon was right all along!
Still, it was not to be.
Instead, those Stabby McDaggers at the Wall
knifed Jon repeatedly "For The Watch", leaving
our favourite bastard bleeding to death in
the snow.
And whose betrayal hurt Jon the most?
Yes, that potato-boy-turned-Ygritte-killer,
Olly.
Those Men in Black are gonna wish they hadn't
been quite so hasty with their daggers if
the Night's King comes knocking at their gate!
But, hold on, is Jon Snow really dead?!
If you want to know my theories on that, check
out this video for my Season 6 predictions
for Jon Snow and The Night's Watch!
The award for most heart-breaking death this
season has to go to Shireen Baratheon.
Even though the fact her character was built
up this season meant we knew in our heart
of hearts that something terrible was in store
for her, the whole build-up to her burning
was just shattering...
the touching talk between her and Davos, and
then that conversation with her father in
which she was SO eager to help him.
Add to that the look on Shireen's face when
she saw Melisandre and the pole she was about
to be tied to, and finally realised what was
happening.
Kerry Ingram gave an incredible performance
as Shireen.
Her cries for her father and mother, followed
by her screams were just chilling.
And when her mother, Selyse, who's never been
Team Shireen, tried to stop her daughter's
sacrifice, while Stannis stood by and let
his baby girl burn; that was another very
powerful moment.
As I've said before, what is the world coming
to when Roose Bolton could actually now beat
Stannis Baratheon in a Father Of The Year
contest?!
Ok, just in case Jon Snow somehow isn't dead,
I'm going to include a bonus death!
In the first episode of the season, when the
King-Beyond-The-Wall, Mance Rayder, refused
to kneel to The One True King, Stannis Baratheon,
Melisandre turned the former Night's Watchman
into a human torch.
But that was not the end of that.
Wildling lover Jon Snow couldn't bear to watch
Mance go up in flames, so he put him out of
his misery with an arrow to the chest.
Oh, and there was something in the way the
camera moved during Jon's shooting of Mance
that made me think back to season 4 when Olly
shot Ygritte.
So, what do you think were the most memorable
deaths in season 5?
Let me know in the comments below!
Honourable mentions go to Mossador, the Lord
of Bones, Janos Slynt, the Daznak's Pit fighters
and all those roasted alive and torn apart
by Drogon before he set off on his Never-ending
Story with Dany.
By the way if you haven't seen it before,
click here for a cool video I made with the
Game Of Thrones cast telling me how they'd
like their characters to die on the show.
And remember, for a chance to win one of Genki
Gear's ten new T-shirts, like the one I'm
wearing, just leave a comment and subscribe!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
And remember, if you're not watching Jan G
on GoT, you know nothing!